oh it is time for drew's news and with
me at the desk every person's dream
pilot ross matthews yes hi everybody hi
hi everybody
hi i said girl once and then i was like
no it just has to be person every person
on the planet if you're alive you want
ross
okay i'll take it thank you i do
um okay first up
we know weddings cost a pretty penny oh
my god and we found one interesting way
to attack that bill now
i found this story quite controversial
okay so newsweek reports that a person
on reddit says their friend katie is a
bride-to-be and she recently told her
friends that she'd be sending around her
venmo account so that they could quote
unquote chip in for the wedding costs
ross
yes
thoughts you're about to get married i
am and katie girl i feel your pain this
then no i i'm about to pass around a
bucket here in the audience collection
seriously i mean i i we're not i i
thought to myself when i first found out
how much the flowers were for a wedding
can i hold a bake sale to raise funds i
see flowers on the side of the road you
want to charge me what it is shocking
how much these things are so katie get
your friends to all chip in
genius katie genius i wonder if she
could pose it like as the wedding
registry like is there something a
little kind of strange about venmo and a
wedding like what if it like a registry
like if you put in this would buy a
bouquet of flowers at table eight you
know i think sometimes people need to
know where their money is going if you
put your money in it will provide this
at this beautiful ceremony i think
that's lovely but give me cold hard cash
all right thank you so much
i'm kidding sort of all right hey next
up we got a
tip should we put your vamo at a lower
third
i mean i'm kidding i don't really want
help but i don't want to shame katie her
friend for doing this and i don't want
to shame katie either i just if i was
your friend i would just want to know
that i was purchasing a certain
something understood how about how about
your chicken dinner at my wedding how
about that's what you're purchasing
all right next up we've got a money
saving tip all the way from japan yeah
and we've got spring cleaning here right
you always hear the people saying that
but in japan apparently they love a good
end of the year scrub they call it osoji
and real simple reports for a natural
and cheap household cleaner you know
what they use
an orange
true this is a tip from the book
simplicity at home by yumiko sikine all
about japanese cleaning techniques step
one
get an orange and then eat it
step two save the peel boil the peel in
water let it simmer for like 15 minutes
and you've got a cleaner for the kitchen
or any surface look right here we have
one here that's yours
um there's an inner piece
that comes with cleaning oh a postcard
um
so
you know
this this is my happy place and i feel
like there's really only so many things
that we can control in life sure look at
it cleaning is something that also is
within your control to make something
clean and not a mess
like messes affect your emotions
hey look drew orange you glad i cleaned
the desk
this smells incredible
too big
okay next up we get a little pep in our
step every time we save money and i can
be riding high on a good promo code for
days and vice reports that the public
library is tapping into this
with new receipts that show you how much
that you have saved by borrowing books
instead of
buying them oh they're keeping track of
that they track all the books that
you've taken out in a year calculate how
much they paid for them
brand new and show you the total amount
that you've saved in the year or in your
lifetime of borrowing and it can be up
to tens of thousands over the course of
the lifetime so
this is amazing yeah do you would go to
the library my mom always checked out
books at the library but i haven't been
able with my library i just i checked
out like a bestseller and forgot to
return it and i got a bunch of late fees
they were very cross with me and i i
know them like i go in there in person
and like talk with them and yeah they
weren't they they were disappointed in
me oh god that's the worst they're
disappointed what did they say to you
just glad it's back
how late were you returning it like four
weeks well now that's fair come on life
gets in the way
i don't go to the library for that very
reason clap of hands who goes to the
library in the audience
really
oh that makes me so happy
apparently you are doing a very fiscally
responsible move and i also just like
love that shared scent and you know the
tactile knowing that like other people
have gone on this adventure too i don't
feel that way when i sit in an airplane
scene i'm not like ooh all the people
i'm more like
but a library book i'm like you're in it
we all did this together
[Music]